après des bombardements dans le nord-est
de l'Ukraine l'armée russe revendique la
prise d'une localité dans la région de
Quercy et affirme avoir gagné du terrain
autour de backmouth où les combats font
rage depuis des mois pour tenir le front
les soldats Ukrainiens réclament encore
plus d'armes à leurs alliés qui sont
réunis à Munich ou la guerre monopolise
les discussions
pour la première fois la vice-présidente
des États-Unis accuse la Russie de
crimes contre l'humanité en Ukraine
citant des tortures et des viols
elle critique aussi la complaisance de
la Chine à l'égard de Moscou qu'elle met
en garde contre toute aide militaire au
Kremlin
[Musique]
le chef de la diplomatie chinoise
rétorque qu'il appartient à Moscou et
qui Ève de trouver une issue politique
au
conflitante de la Commission européenne
veut plutôt redoubler les efforts dans
le soutien militaire acquieve notamment
en accélérant la production d'armements
standard comme les munitions pour le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN aussi le
temps presse
Vladimir Poutine mobilise des centaines
de milliers de troupes dit-il selon lui
une défaite de l'Ukraine pourrait donner
des idées aux autres dirigeants
autoritaires
le ministre ukrainien des Affaires
étrangères demande des avions de combat
et exhorte ses alliés de commencer les
formations des soldats Ukrainiens
rapidement dans les rues de Munich ces
discussions ont trouvé leur écho des
centaines de personnes ont manifesté
certaines pour soutenir le crâne
d'autres au contraire pour exprimer leur
désaccords à la livraison d'armes au
pays ici Camille ferraizen Radio-Canada
Montréal